[Music]
xenomorphs and symbiotes share a lot in
common than you thought they did they
are alien species not native to earth
and they are monstrous hard to kill
creatures that have an insatiable need
to kill
so the question now is if the clinton
are symbiotes the ones like venom can
defeat and kill a xenomorph now let's
dive in more into this by looking at
every aspect of both these monsters and
decide which ones are more powerful
okay let's start with origins firstly
the klintar also known as the symbiotes
are a species of inorganic amorphous
symbiotic extraterrestrials created by
the primordial entity
called null null amassed a large army
and established himself as the hive mind
utilizing them to conquer many worlds
and destroy entire civilizations over
billions of years
well on the other hand there are two
origin stories for the xenomorphs the
most dominant theory is that space
engineers made them as the perfect bio
weapon
another is that the xenomorphs were
created and perfected by an android name
david as seen in the movie alien
covenant but they have always been
designed to wipe out life and other
perfect bio weapons
so what's the biology difference between
these two creatures
the symbiotes are amorphous beings that
infect a host and survive within the
host when they are compatible even
though they are created out of darkness
they can also create offsprings by
themselves by asexual means such as
detaching parts of themselves and also
they also come out from eggs as in the
case of venom the xenomorphs however
have a very different biology as
compared to a clinton they are product
of genetic engineering and originally
come out from acts as face huggers and
these small creatures implant an embryo
within the hose which later comes out as
a chest burster juvenile which will grow
exponentially in size over the span of a
few hours into an adult
anyway back to the clinton when bonded
with any host a symbiote can interface
with their genomes and physiology the
host would be covered with the amorphous
form of the symbiote and display
increased strength durability and
ability to create weapons out of their
own body the xenomorphs however aren't
part of their host but they develop
within their hosts and the adult
specimen will differ depending upon the
type of species they grow inside it
interfacing with their genes and coming
out as a sort of a hybrid creature
so what are the powers of these two
aliens the xenomorph have remarkable
physical strength and agility once
completely matured they are masters of
stealth they have been found to be
capable of withstanding extreme physical
damage that would kill any form of life
they can survive limb amputations
tubbings and even head shots they are
swift and agile climbers who can scale
any surface they can survive in every
environment any temperature and even in
the vacuum of space their teeth and
secondary mouth as well as their
spear-tipped tails are their lethal
weapons their acidic blood is the most
hazardous characteristic of part of them
as it can burn through even metal
on the other hand symbiotes seem to have
some latent psychic abilities allowing
them to respond to the thoughts of their
hosts and also of each other all
symbiotes have the ability to form
tendril-like limbs venom has used this
to great effect by forming tendrils and
shields from his constituted matter
carnage discharges tendrils of his
constituted matter into his opponents
additionally they have the power to form
solid appendages from their bodies and
have been shown to form spikes talons
and blades they can survive the
harshness of space and most atmospheres
the life foundation symbiotes have also
been seen and shown to form a very
powerful asset from their constitutive
matter and also they are bulletproof
so both of these are magnitudes more
powerful than humans but the symbiotes
when bonded with a human is much
stronger as we can all see the
xenomorph's acidic blood won't be much
of an advantage as the symbiotes can
also form acid from their constituted
matter although both are very durable we
have seen xenomorphs being decapitated
and killed by gunshots and blades but
nowhere has a symbiote been seen killed
by such things to put this in simple
terms the xenomorph has no specific
weaponry for these creatures and they
can't even use fire against them the
symbiotes however are let's face it
physically more powerful and resistant
to acidic blood their agility and brute
strength would be too much for a
xenomorph or even a large group of them
the only chance xeno has is to kill the
symbiote when it is separated from its
host and in its pure form
so what are your thoughts do put them
down in the comments section below and
so with that we come to the end of the
video do remember to hit that like
button for support and subscribe to be a
part of the mind cue family and also
ring that bell icon for regular updates
when we post new monster content right
here on this channel till the next one
take care fam